our top story right here out of New York
Alvin Bragg is now sweating even more
than usual tonight now his his
pathetically weak case against former
president Trump has totally imploded
let's be very clear here the case died
this very week it is very obvious it is
very clear it's transparent Alvin Bragg
had every intention of indicting Donald
J Trump this week but for the second
straight day grand jury proceedings were
canceled today now Bragg is now telling
Reuters that it was former president
Donald Trump that created a false
expectation of arrest
it was never actually going to happen
according to Bragg it seems really after
a multi-year investigation the formation
of a grand jury the DA's meeting with
law enforcement to coordinate an
impending arrest of a former Vice former
president and we're supposed to believe
that somehow Donald Trump created the
false expectation of arrest now the New
York Times they reported of course
Pulitzer prize-winning group that they
are based on fake news anyway they
reported that criminal charges against
Trump were likely on March the 9th
that's when they first did it remember
Maggie Haberman a Pulitzer Prize winner
for a story she got wrong on the Russian
hoax she was all over fake news CNN
saying yeah looks like it's going to
happen well that story was out nine days
before Donald Trump even mentioned it
untruth social his his uh platform so I
don't think it was Donald Trump that
created the expectation it was actually
Bragg the media mob and his office
probably leaking to the New York Times
and probably others and now it looks
like Bragg is having trouble delivering
on his campaign promise he promised
during the campaign that he would go
after one man Donald Trump one company
the Trump organization one family the
Trump family and as most of you know by
now the DA's entire case relied on the
testimony of a serial liar and a
convicted felon by the name of Michael
Cohn and this week for the very first
time the grand jury actually heard the
truth about Cohn from somebody who's not
a Serial liar who's not an ex-con but he
heard we heard from his former legal
advisor right here on this show Bob
Costello and he blows Michael cohn's
story right out of the water take a look
what do you have on Donald Trump and
that's when he started with the same
litany that he used for the rest of the
two hours I swear to God Bob I don't
have anything on Donald Trump but the
point is when somebody is is really
thinking of committing suicide and
you're offering them a legal way out of
this if he had any information about
Donald Trump that would have been the
one time even for a Serial liar like
Michael Cohen to to fess up and say well
I know this or that because I'm I want
to save my own hide but he didn't do
that Michael Cohn who as I said before
was pacing back and forth would suddenly
stop in the middle of whatever he was
talking about and turn and point his
finger at us and say I want you guys to
understand I will do whatever the f I
have to do I will never spend a day in
jail he said that at least 10 to 20
times during that two-hour period it was
it was a bizarre Mantra but it made it
clear to us that Michael Cohen was
saying saying I will lie cheat steal
shoot someone I will never spend a day
in jail wow powerful testimony that
happened this week now Cohn said to
Costello many times I have nothing on
Donald Trump and not only did Costello
destroy the credibility of the state
star witness uh Cohn McCone himself
completely contradicts the state's case
then look at this newly uncovered
document this is from 2018. this is from
Michael cone's own lawyer to the FEC
quote in a private transaction in 2016
before the u s presidential election Mr
Cohn used his own personal funds to
facilitate a payment of a hundred and
thirty thousand dollars to miss
Stephanie Clifford neither the Trump
organization or the Trump campaign was a
party to the transaction with Miss
Clifford so is Cohn lying under oath now
or during that statement to the FEC now
of course at the very center of the case
is a completely legal what's called an
NDA over an alleged Affair from 2007.
there is zero evidence whatsoever that
the Trump campaign paid for this NDA as
a matter of fact Cohn says they did not
and there's no evidence they played a
role in the NDA in fact there's no
evidence that the affair in question
ever took place people people can
believe what they want but there's no
evidence of it according to the
Washington Post of all places Stormy
Daniels denied the affair multiple
multiple times including in writing on
January 30th 2018. this is a letter that
was obtained by TMZ take a look at your
screen quote I am not denying this
affair because I was paid quote hush
money I am denying this affair because
it never happened even Stormy Daniels
former lawyer justicenews.com John
Solomon breaking tonight Michael
avenatti he's in prison but he's
tweeting in prison
I can't figure that one out uh but he's
tweeted out that many critical pieces of
evidence have yet to see the light of
day will be very damaging to the
prosecution so let me get this straight
the D.A in Manhattan Alvin Bragg
dedicated thousands of hours uh millions
of tax dollars to a case surrounding a
legal NDA over an alleged Affair from
2007 that both parties deny based on
allegations from a Serial liar convicted
felon Michael Cohn who was hell-bent on
getting revenge against his former boss
now a low-level felony that is so weak
so convoluted and possibly even outside
the statute of limitations that a grand
jury in deep blue New York City might
very well and seems to be rejecting it
now keep in mind you can indict a ham
sandwich in a grand jury you don't need
a unanimous verdict and the only and
only the prosecution gets to present
evidence in other words the defense gets
zero opportunity to even speak to the
grand jury let alone present any
evidence that they have and it appears
that Bragg has failed to pass that very
very very low bar in this case it seems
he can't indict a ham sandwich now this
is humility sorry I can't resist
this is humiliating for the DA's office
and infuriating for the people of New
York Bragg wasted precious time and
resources over a political hit job that
probably won't ever see the light of day
while very real criminals violent
criminals are roaming the streets of New
York City every day hey Sean Hannity
here hey click here to subscribe to Fox
News YouTube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else